Hello
and welcome everyone to Active Inference
Lab, to the Gueststream -
the Active Iinference Gueststream number
2.1 on March 18th 2021
featuring Dimitris Bolis
and this is going to be a really awesome
discussion on a wide variety of topics.
So I'll just pass it to Dimitris
to introduce himself and take it away.
We're going to have a presentation first
and then we'll be documenting questions
from the live chat.
So please drop
any thoughts or questions in there
and then we'll have a discussion
after this presentation.
So thanks again for coming on the stream.
We really appreciate the time
and please take it away.
Hello, everybody,
and very happy being here.
Thank you very much, the organizers for
organizing
and presenting such an interesting
series of short seminars.
So today I will like to present to you
a work that we have been doing
primarily in the last six years
in Munich
in collaboration with Zilber
and his group in my splint and
basically the title contractor
for AM Human Be Coming In
and Through Social Interaction
is the title of my piece,
the dissertation
that I was presented
last year about this month.
So for anybody
that would like more details
at the end of the talk, the good,
the always go back to the document,
it's already published in ResearchGate.
And there, there you can find also the
already first papers
that came out from this work but
more are coming
in the way in the next few months.
So I will start by
presenting
the outline of this presentation.
So first
we will go through the theoretical work
which consists of the dialectical human
hypothesis.
And then let me set human
hypotheses, which are both
focused and emphasize
the importance of social interaction
in human becoming across both contexts
from and various case from evolution
to cultural development
and psychopathology.
Then importantly, we will discuss
concrete empirical physiologies
with regards
to how we can put into the formal test
this kind of hypothesis and which we call
two person psycho physiology.
Because this work tries to extend
the traditional psycho physiology work
in the social domain.
So we will see how, based on
coming to research, for example,
we aim to create different streams
of studying
for monitoring,
recording and analyzing data
in high resolution from multiple people.
At the same time that we are able
to interact in real time,
then we will go through the
empirical work and the first two studies,
which is
about interpersonal attunement
in real time social interactions
and especially through JS, and second
about the interpersonal use of humans
in real life social relationships.
And this is with regard
to autistic traits
and interpersonal similarity.
And fourth,
we will discuss some scientific
and the societal implications
of this work and
we will conclude.
So the theoretical work is based on
two main pillars that's
a philosophical framework
developed across many centuries.
Going back to some years and in Greece
and also
in China or India
and we will go through
more details later.
But this was developed
further in more modern times,
especially in France, in Germany,
and also we lean
upon heavily
the mainstream brain hypothesis and
especially the framework of predictive
processing and active inference.
So I guess most of the people
here might be already familiar
with these frameworks
but I would like to go through
a simple example
and just to make clear the
principle
and implications
of this kind of frameworks.
So let us imagine,
Lady waking up late for her work and
so she cannot decide
what to wear for going to work
but based on her previous experience
and she lives in the south
part of Greece in Crete,
she believes that
most probably
the weather will be good and sunny.
So she decides to go out
without putting an umbrella or a coat.
However, these days, the sunlight
so this is
contrary to her predictions.
The weather was raining
and they should go with the second day,
even though she believes that
the probability for raining might be 5%.
So increase here.
The probability she believes
about the probability of raining
and how obviously still is deciding
not in umbrella.
This continues for a week
where you finally
have time to come to believe
the probability of raining
even in this period
and this place was 90%
and decided to carry an umbrella.
So we see here how she gradually updated
her beliefs based on the evidence
that we observed in real life
and gradually
let us imagine
another illustrative example.
The same lady goes for vacations to Japan
and she again is late to go out
and she has not decided
whether she needs to carry an umbrella
with or not
based on rumors.
In this time she again
believes that the weather will be good.
So she's slightly dressed.
However, again, she's a year unlucky
and the weather is raining
so already.
And in this case,
and the lady, for example,
and this is for this
from the second day already
she believes that
the probability of framing will be 90%.
So we see here in some
regarding the show
updating of the weather beliefs.
Why is that happening here
from aberration perspective
one could argue that in this case
that her beliefs
were formed
quickly through social rumors.
They were more or less confident
so more susceptible to change
when faced with contradictory evidence.
But a very important
factor in the base and been hypothesis.
So we'll go through
the mathematical details,
but with this very simple
and simplifying examples, we examine
two cardinal aspects of such account,
namely the updating of beliefs
and through integrating prior
knowledge and new data
and also
we examine the learning rate of
this procedure, which is thought of as
a way to precision prediction error,
which means that the more confident
we are about our previous beliefs,
the less likely we are to
update them
in face of contradictory information.
So this framework
to gain much attention
over the last two years.
First, because as we see, we can it's
useful in examining
various real life scenarios
and puts them into formal equations
and models which can be formally examined
and tested against one another
so of course, the
outline of this account that we've drawn
so far, it's rather simplistic.
So in this case,
we only examined the scenario
that one person observes
passively the world, and
their only choice
is to update their beliefs
according to what they observe.
So this is countries which have
mentioned resembles in some aspects
the old Plato's Cave allegory,
where two months were
and nothing else, that prisoners
from the whole
for the whole lives in a deep cave
where they never experience
the outer world.
And their only experience about the
environment was to projections
on a wall
through shadows of the real objects
that are reflected
on the wall in front of them.
So this we can imagine
in a way
humans or other organisms
experiencing the world in a manner
right,
such as we have specific sensory organs
where an information from
the world is projected
and we selectively experience
the reality of this.
Of course, this is just a partial
image of what is happening.
One already awake
and think of a second avenue
of an attunement
between the organism and the environment.
So as we said,
if I said the organism tries to
minimize prediction error
through perception of learning
by adjusting their own beliefs
to the environment, but of course
an organism can also update their beliefs
through action so that they selectively
transform
into some the world in a way
that it conforms
to their initial beliefs.
So this, I contend, constitutes
a more comprehensive
account of organisms, life
and especially human life.
But we will argue in line
with other recent accounts
in this talk that this is
occurring is still not enough on its own
because it considers individual organisms
out of context.
Out of their social context,
and especially with regards to humans,
out of the crucial cultural context
as well.
In our effort
to embed these kind of accounts,
we have leaned on
the political approach,
which is an we saw before.
It consists in constitutes
a school of thought,
which goes back to infant years
and continues until
this years, always
in reaching different historical context.
So the importance of this framework
is that it emphasizes
unity of phenomena and it doesn't neglect
inner contradictions
and emphasize
movement or phenomena or change
and so a
situation of crisis or radical changes,
it doesn't seem to
this account is problematic.
But also instances of
updating
and embracing.
So this kind of accounts try to overcome
the economies
such as the organism and the environment,
the individual collective,
or as we will see in our work,
even a patient versus their cultural
context
and special emphasis is given
not only in intro level courses,
but also between level processes
across various temporal states
so this account goes against
both dualism and reductionism
as it tries to examine
phenomena in the wholeness
but without
metaphysically assuming
independent levels of reality
and traditionally sciences
for good reasons, for some
for lack of tools
to focus on specific levels
of description of reality,
such as, for example,
the physical or biological level
or the psycho physiological level.
This kind of
studies to provided important insight
however, when examined
and isolated in a single level,
we will argue it doesn't provide
the whole picture of complex phenomena
such as psycho social, cultural
or psychiatric phenomena.
So in this work, we have argued that
even deploying simple research paradigms
will be crucial to try to
probe and monitor processes
that live on different levels
of description
based on this
assumption,
we have reviewed human becoming
as a dialectic of internalization
and externalization and more precisely
connected internalization processes
to predictive processing
with as we saw from
our examples, is the
mechanism of updating our own beliefs
in order
to conform
to the environmental regularities.
And we connect these externalization
processes and
especially collective externalization
of processes to active inference,
which is a process of co
regulating the outer world,
and especially the social world.
And according to our
inner beliefs,
but also according to our collective
inner beliefs.
And one can see a human
becoming this attunement with the world
and both physical worlds and others.
So here we see how we can or
how an organism such as animals or humans
and trying to regulate
the world, both physical
and social, will
and by acting on the world.
So, for example, in this case,
this this animal holds
the world against gravity first.
That means that already
in an embodied way,
captures the physical dynamics
of Earth's gravity
but also acts against social events
here and attempt to from somebody taking
the more
so we see
human becoming is
the little of human mean in our scale.
And in that cell,
as in their personal,
we say that in this kind of regularity,
same multi scale
model of on an individual
level and vice versa.
And this can happen from across
different scales
from the field of Genesis culture
in terms of tendencies
to everyday learning, decision
making perception and even so called
into automatic introspective process
our perspective
draws heavily on a victim perspective
who have famously declared
the claim that through others
we become ourselves.
So in order to
further illuminate this view,
let us imagine a simple
example.
Let us imagine a little baby that
am feeling
hungry as the intercept of systems
is out of balance and tries
to reach for food.
However, the motor repertoire of
such a human being,
it's not developed yet fully
and so
these babies are unable
to reach for food on its own.
So what happens
is that the usually the caregiver
will notice that kind of behavior in it.
And it will try to satisfy that,
for example, by placing the food
closer to the baby.
So in this case, we see
we can even imagine
how this kind of interpersonal relation
between the caregiver
and the baby results
may result in a internalization
and then both in its a symbolic level
of this kind of process.
So the baby both
across evolution and development,
might come to realize
that when extending the harmful
the index finger
and calls for attention
and pointing to a specific
object that they need
so we see how
an interpersonal relationship based on
natural needs for survival
might end up
being an internalization of it
in on a symbolic level
so here that example is important
talk because this illustrates
how a collective level,
a level of description of process
between people
might be transformed
into single brains
and single bodies processes
and actually makes us
what we are becoming
and that is humans and growing up
in these kind of accounts
are very much in line with the framework
of amateurism and especially
the account of participatory sense
making,
which has focused a lot
on the fundamental role
of social interactions
and both from individual sense making,
which is always affected
by coordination dynamics while we are in
embedded in social interactions
all the way to design.
Since making how that means,
how we and jointly with others
make sense of the world
however, this kind of account might seem
theoretical
so now here we will
ask the question
How can we apply this kind of ideas,
and why is it even important to reflect
on these processes and whether the
these processes lie on
lower level of descriptions
or collective levels or between?
So to illustrate an example,
we will use autism
as a paradigm example,
and we will try to illustrate
how these ideas can be concrete
and then concretely put into practice.
So autism spectrum condition
has been described
as a pervasive developmental condition,
which is characterized by difficulties
in social interaction and communication,
as well as restricted interest interests
and all sensory behaviors.
So that's the traditional
typical definition
of autism spectrum conditions
and to some predominant approaches
so far, so focused on difficulties
or so-called impairments
or theory of mind, these theories
describe autism as a condition
that individuals have problems with
an understanding of intentions.
Other them
or beliefs of other people.
So there's also
there are also alternative hypotheses
such as this social motivation hypothesis
which claims
that people with autism
have usually diminished
social motivation
to interact with others.
So in this case,
they might lack opportunities
in gaining and
more cognitive abilities.
We see also a weak
central coherence account
and or executive dysfunction,
which seems refers
to more individual characteristics
of individuals
with autistic individuals
such as difficulties with planning,
or you're paying more attention
to global,
sorry, local information
rather than information.
And we also see broken mirror on your own
hypotheses which
emphasize the difficulty of autism
and autistic people
when it comes to empathizing
and more recently,
we have computational approaches
such as the aberrant or inflexible
precision updating,
which
grounded in predictive
processing account,
and the claim that autism
might result from
an aberrant way
of updating precision and the
more concretely regulating
the updating of beliefs
as we so by integrating
previously getting experience
with in face
of newly income information.
So we see here that
this type of account there are either
more social accounts right.
Right.
This area of mine social deviation,
broken meter, new account,
or even the abrupt precision of dating
when it comes to the social world.
However, and
even in this case where others
into and into the frame,
the condition is exclusively attributed
and examined
within single individuals
and especially a single brain.
So the
most predominant causes of autism
focus on individuals and try to diagnose
or even treat
such conditions by paying attention
primarily on the individual
so for example, in research, it's
common to
identify two groups, for example, one
so called neurotypical
or non autistic group
and to one autistic group.
And then by
deploying a specific paradigm
we try to identify
traditionally differences
in behavioral patterns for brain function
and this kind of paradigms then
attribute these kind of differences in
the efficient functioning of the autistic
so however,
there's a lot to do here and in line with
and in the subjective term,
in the research of psychopathology
and specifically in autism,
we will see how
by including real time
social interactions
and social relationships
and we can expand this focus
from individual brains
to a process between people
and especially in communication so
this line of
work would suggest
that it's not enough to identify
two different groups of people
like neurotypical and autistic people.
But already by beginning examining
diets of people or groups of people,
one can not really see where we are
or have available here at least three
different broad categories of
partners, for example.
And now kids,
we have neurotypical partners,
we have autistic partners,
but we have also mixed
partners.
Which means consisting of
at least one autistic individual
and at least one neurotypical individual.
So in this case,
I hypothesis has been that
at least in certain levels,
especially in the exponential level,
the autistic individuals
will entertain similar levels
of smoothness, interactive smoothness
as they neurotypical partners,
where is makes
that might appear in certain levels
interacting less efficiently.
And if that hypothesis is correct,
then one can see that
the deficiency
doesn't lie
in the individual brain of the autistic.
But at least partially,
we can look at it in process
between individuals.
This is very much in line
with the problem
of Damian Middleton,
who have argued that the ideology
of accepting of him autism condition
does not lie in the individual,
but it comes from mismatches of
social abilities or expectations.
One can imagine even
I probing this further
by not necessarily
victimizing people in autistic
or non autistic or any other category
we can imagine, but rather
examining.
And so it's traits on a continuum
and then
examining the
interaction, smoothness based
on the distance of people
in a space of conditions rather than in
a single dimensional spectrum.
Of conditions.
Later we will see how
this can be operationalized.
So let's
I this example as we already
mentioned, the last decade
especially, but also before through
a more sociological account
we have seen
and in this objective term
in the study of autism
and other conditions
and just to give a few examples
and focus on the problem, this argues
that social difficulties
in autism arises
to a complication
and the military side in single brains
also, as we saw in activist
and participatory science
making account to claim
that atypical abuse can be
viewed as a different way of making sense
of others and interacting with a world
or second person.
And neuropsychology perspectives
have claimed that social difficulties
are more likely or even only
manifest themselves in real time
social interactions,
whereas more passive
scenarios might be less problematic
clinically
and finally,
a part of this work, the election,
which assumes hypothesis
has an bring together in the subjective
approaches and predictive quotient
pricing approaches
to reviews and conditions
such as autism's autism
but also other conditions.
Notice a disorder of the individual,
but rather
as a cumulative depression of humans.
So in a nutshell, in
the presence of human
can be thought of as disturbances
of a dynamic and reciprocal unfolding,
of an interaction across multiple time
scales, resulting in increasingly
divergent prediction
and interaction styles
or patterns and vice versa.
And we saw the hypothesis
aligned with our account holds
clear predictions.
And so before we start
experimenting empirically,
we make concrete hypotheses
in terms of interactions
which
we suggested as interaction
between homogeneous and non shown
dyads are expected to I'm sorry,
into autoimmune diets as
compared to
heterogeneous diets or non shown diets.
We will see later what we mean
by social attune
tend to be homogeneous or
more importantly,
we see here an interplay between levels
of description between the the subjective
community group
and individual prediction
and interaction styles,
which might appear diverse
across people of different conditions
and so we see how in initially
the subjective
community of group can result in
increasing individual
divergence,
the prediction and direction styles.
And so as we have people
of higher form diverse
social expectations about each other,
how this can result in increasing
subsuming the subjective community across
which case one can imagine, for example,
at the scale of a dialog
for example,
let's say I start with making a comment
that another person might take
is insulting.
Then the other person
replies
to me barking in an aggressive manner.
Then I'm sorry, I'm starting
feeling angry
and this can escalate
potentially in a major vicious human
in the scale of just few seconds
or a few minutes especially.
This can happen between people,
for example, that have cultivated
to distinct systems of beliefs
for some different cultures,
and they don't that have a chance
to get to know other systems of beliefs
and this
in the case of autism, for example,
this one can imagine that this kind of
interactions might play out during
a course development.
So a child in a school, for example,
that I would children
are not informed about
different communication styles
might isolate,
exclude and isolate this child
so I would term forcing this child to
develop with
decreased level of social interaction.
We see this
not only in terms with autism, also
about with regards to other social
communicative differences.
And people can be excluded, for example,
immigration
populations in new places
might be excluded initially
based on this kind of
in the subjective community of groups
so in our case,
going back to autism,
we will try to personalize
the homogeneity of diet of partners
the similarity
of in terms of autistic traits
we can which we can measure with standard
questionnaire tests and to we will
operationalize
in our experiments
the weakness of an interaction
based on the perceived friendship
quality,
again,
through questionnaires, for example.
But later
we will see how we can extend this work
in a more fine grained time scales.
For example,
in at the scale of milliseconds
when it comes to interpersonal behavior
or interpersonal social expression
behavior.
So our experimental methodology
takes the form of two person
cycle physiology
or collective psycho physiology,
which tries to expand the study of psycho
physiological phenomena
into the sociable collective domain
and here
our a study on
the interpersonal attunement in real time
social interactions
make use of this methodology
which is grounded in and second
personal neuroscience accounts
which which claim that in real time
social interaction,
the brain or other processes
might be fundamentally different
than a simpler passive
social, social,
passive observation of scenarios.
So when we really interact
with another in real time, for example,
in the discussion
of this account
and hypothesize that our brain
will function in different, qualitatively
different and quantitatively
different way as when we just sit back
and observe others,
we saw the opportunity
to feedback to each other.
We'll go
in detail
here about their brain processes
and our study here
will see mainly behavioral results.
So also our two persons physiology
framework is based on previous work
over the last couple of decades,
such as, for example, if MRI
or EEG hyper scanning,
you'll see
one of the seminal works of Duma,
which
connected to EEG systems
into into the same computer
in order to at the same time
examine the brain function of two people
while
interacting
through
hand movements
also other
networks, such as work from local
school coaching and have examined
the phenomenon, for example,
from deepening the brain with the use of
hyper scanning and all across development
our two to set up, it looks like both.
So I'll go here and also in detail,
just want to make clear
that our system is deploys
different in several different
recording modalities
and in a completely symmetrical way
in order to make sure that we in perfect
synchronicity, we can monitor
the individual processes of two
or more people
from decision making to eye movement
and facial expressions
into brain function all at the same time
so that we can interrelate
first processes
of different modalities
within the same person.
How decision making is
connected to our
emotional processing
or facial expressions
and how we, our brain function
modulate eye movements and
and how our perceived social information
modulates brain function.
And second, to interrelate
in the multimodal
processes of individuals
with one another.
So how my
visual information, for example,
influence your behavior
and how your behavior influenced me
in a closed loop
so in reality, our set up
looks like that.
So two persons are invited in the lab
and they sort of
simple visual tasks
while they are able to communicate
and interact through a micro camera
of the center of the screen,
which deploys
the face of the other person in.
So here in our first experiment,
the important manipulation was that
when people were able to communicate
in real time, like in a Skype manner
in half of a game, and people
could not communicate in real time
because they replayed
the part of the video
of the previous interaction
without letting people know
so in our game, the two people
so that they always communicated
in real time.
However,
contrary to their perception
in half of the game,
they really communicated.
But in half of the game they just observe
the video of the other person
and so in this case,
we will be able to disentangle
quantitatively the impact
of these social interaction dynamics,
even in the absence of conscious
interpretation of the situation
so here we can see our two main
conditions of the live video feed.
What allows the two people
to form a system, the one system
interacting system, and in the other case
we have two distinct systems,
cognitive systems. We test or observe
recorded
videos of the other without knowing
our them looks like that.
It's based
on a seminal work of Bardo
Bahrami and colleagues in London
it's a cycle physiological and
task where we ask people to identify
the odd object on the screen
without knowing that
there is no object object on the screen.
So because we have four possible
possibilities, left or right, up or down,
I we expect just a 25%
chance of coherence
between the decisions of the two persons.
So whatever, whatever weeks we observe
and above and beyond to 25%
am in a statistically significant manner
we can attribute.
And just on the dynamics
of the switching production,
because every other piece
of information
remains the same for the two people
except for the dynamics of
their interaction three years
so for example, here you can see Case one
and we have covered the eyes of people
for privacy reasons.
And but here you can see how people
in real time, even when they don't
see the face of her face
together, present
their synchronized and happy
interacting together at the same time.
Look here for some,
how perfectly aligned is even the
first two expressions
the same here we cannot see the eyes,
but the same will say about the eyes.
The same happens.
People tend to follow each other eyes.
But let's see now a second change
where people same game the same day.
After a few seconds, they played
a version of the game where without
knowing one person, see only the video
of the eyes of the other person.
So in this case, you see people
start being confused, like,
why don't you follow me
as they follow you?
ET cetera.
So this creates a mix of human
and artificial human.
Were people naive about our experiment?
Control cannot attribute to
a power manipulations, but
as we saw through questionnaires,
the asking group,
the through
psychological interpretations,
like the other person, was both all tied
so at some point or
two, for example,
we can see how the interpersonal
interpersonal of humans play out
in the behavioral domain and especially
here in how to gaze
transitioning to person coincides
and for each other like independent
interacting and better creatures
thank you for your results.
And based on our analysis of the again
strings here we can see
we formed three experimental conditions.
We said one sugar condition
where we suffered dyads
from different days and we see that
they're against continuation.
The green is the lowest there.
We see that when people really observe
the other person in the room,
the yellow them.
So the orange distribution,
we see that we have an increased
coordination
metric.
But what really made a difference
is when people are allowed
to really interact with each other,
we see that their gains space was
synchronized the most.
And very interestingly, we observe
exactly the same pattern
in terms of
of a completely different
level of description.
And we see the decision
making alignment again here.
We see that when we analyzed data
from people of different partners,
we see that in this either
the probability of agreeing on
the same object was around 25%.
We see here
the green distribution centers around 25.
Then we see that the orange distribution
already on the
about the observation
scenario is slightly increased.
But what it was an increase was the
decision making alignment in
the real time social interaction tonight.
Also this is reflected
in the interrelationship
between the two modalities we see here
both in the online and offline
conditions we see and statistical
in the relationship
between the two modalities
so the more the gains coordinate,
the higher the coordination, the higher
the decision making alignment.
And we also see that
the in the case of real tension
construction,
this interrelationship appeared stronger
also another interesting finding
is that the the confidence
difference between the two conditions
was significant.
So people, without even knowing
that there was two different conditions,
appear more confident
about their own choices.
And depending
in their real time
social interaction situations,
as opposed to the offline or
social observation scenarios.
So so here we see
how the social interaction dynamics,
even when we don't
we are not aware of them consciously it
influences us phenomena logically,
even to the level of our confidence
about our own decision
making.
So finally,
we also see a relationship between Gaze
coordination
and the perceived level of collaboration.
So the more people
follow each other, gaze
the more likely we are to report
a higher level
of satisfaction in collaboration.
So what we have established to
where we examine
the best memories of human
in this time in Real-Life
Social Relationships, here we try to move
our empirical studies
outside of the lab in the real world
without performing any manipulation,
just by collecting
registering the experiences,
the real life experiences of
people in the real world.
So here we study the link
more concretely between this similarity
of artistic traits
and friendship ratings along a continuum
and for that, to this end,
we invited virtual friends
to complete questionnaires
about their individual artistic traits
and the quality of their friendship
without being able to communicate
their replies, of course, to each other.
Then we analyzed this data
that we gathered from
140 for neurotypical adults,
which form to 72
same sex diets of friends
which whose
friendship duration of our age
alone from three months to 30 years,
and they're meeting frequency again,
whereas diverse
from a few times
per year to daily in the ages
of other wholes from 19 years old
to 15 years
and balanced in terms of sex
sample of participants here
we see the distributions
of their main
measures of our study
friendship quality friendship duration
autistic trace and opposite face mismatch
which is simply the difference
of my autistic traits
versus your basic traits
in a given value of friendship.
This study was
recently published, so
indices can go back into all the details.
So in a nutshell,
I what we find here is that
whereas individual autistic
traits were really related
with the principle quality in line
with previous studies
in our study of real life
social relationships, this
apparent relation was not significant
statistically, at least in the amount
of our sample size and
as we see, and it only appeared to show
a very weak interrelationship,
what was more
interesting was the as hypothesized,
the relationship
between the mismatch of autistic face
and the friendship quality.
And here we see that
the more the mismatch of autistic traits,
so the more different
the two people were in a given day,
the less satisfied appear in their
in their friendship
and this result was irrespective
of friendship, duration, age, sex
or even be able to say this these traits
and similar observations we found
with regard to
friendship duration,
we found no interrelation
in the relationship at all
between friends in duration,
individual autistic traits in our sample.
But we indeed found
an interrelationship between
mismatch of autistic traits
and friendship duration.
So the key consequence
of friendship quality that contributed to
this kind of results
were interpersonal acceptance, closeness.
And so
so based on our empirical observations,
we can speculate and suggest the future
directions of research, relevant work
which will examine the
dialectical phenomenon
between different levels
of analysis from the collective
to the individual and back.
So for example, in this case,
we can speculate that
potentially potential higher
interpersonal attunement
between people might lead
to smoother social interactions,
which in turn
might transform our interactions in
with another person
and in a more rewarding form.
So we are more happy to communicate
with a specific person.
And this
may have
been found to enhance
even interpersonal attraction about term,
and this attraction might increase
the motivation to interact further
and to more frequent.
The interaction with the other
might boost interaction with success.
And this impression of success might
contribute back to higher interpersonal
with humans.
Of course, such a process, simplification
and more experiments
are needed
to examine the different stages of such a
a procedure in real life.
So in our discussion, we'll examine
some limitations
and future direction of our work.
First
we can
and should measure
more finding mechanisms
in a more clearly modulatory experiments
using hyper scanning and computational
modeling
in order to tap into a more
detail mechanisms
of this kind of phenomenon.
Also, in the future, we can
deploy unmediated
face to face interactions
such as real life monitoring of
verbal thoughts and behavior.
We should
examine also a more heterogeneous
assumption of the population
for example, of mixed gender, population
or cross-cultural diets and groups
or even
groups of the same cultural,
but of different
socioeconomic background
or educational background.
Certain scales of social interaction
dynamics can be incorporated
and here we drawing on
the left instrument hypothesis,
we suggest to continue
with longitudinal tracking of two person
and collective psychopathology
so that we also monitor the
development of such kind of attunement
or resettlement
across several years in real life
scenarios.
Also,
clinical studies are needed in order
to examine these kind of hypotheses
across as we saw different types of dyads
or groups
which will include autistic
or other condition
dyads, typical ones, but also
mixed ones
indeed, which have already started
in collaboration
with victims, OK, and lexical cohesion
to deploying such studies in order to tap
into their brain mechanisms
using both EEG, hyper scanning,
ephemera, type scanning, and hopefully
shown in.
These are gone
when the situation stabilizes
in terms of the content
and also we at the same time
analyze for some expressions
between two people
and here
we also already saw how two people
might synchronize expressions
when they interact
in real time
potential ghost and similar along
with what we showed before.
So before concluding,
I would like to draw a sketch
of our future computational glance.
Here we have
on a paper which is called Beyond One
Base and Brain.
We have suggested that we should go
beyond an individual Bayesian
modeling of being isolated
brain towards and collective models
which will capture both interests,
objective beliefs and interests,
objective confidence of beliefs,
but also intersubjective coupling
here in this
paper
from 2007,
we were based on previous
work of Don Izzo
and Chris Mathis which is
developed around the metabolism
to level and
meters from skin
and for concluding if
we should to mention that then
especially in the last two
or three years, more and more evidence
appearing in favor of
a viewing psychopathology
as an interpersonal attunement
and not only as exclusively
a disorder of the brain
and to if this evidence,
at least in certain levels
of description, holds
so valid and robust, one can imagine that
apart from examining
and treating an individual
and diagnosing individuals,
we can pass through a more
comprehensive social approaches
where we will
at the same time treating an individual
with a certain condition.
But at the same time,
we will also inform the society about
these conditions.
So in a way, our approach points towards
not shunning only persons
with specific condition
into the incidental norm
of our current cultural context.
But tries to foster
an interpersonal meeting
as a model, if you will,
so for example, of course,
we don't suggest deploying,
for example, to psychopharmacology
in the general population,
but for example, with
informational campaigns in schools
and we did such and such
is a tuning of social expectations of
or enrichment, if you will,
in order
to provide a more inclusive society
for everybody
also approach approach
points towards
a treatment of the into interaction
assets in line with on a participatory
sense making traditions where we envision
modern schools, for example,
that would care about
tuning the medium of communication
between people.
For example, in a previous work we have
suggested developing educational systems
mediated through computers
or even social robotics
or serious gaming
between two individuals,
which could alleviate
some initial social pressures
and allow people to communicate smoother
in the first steps of
development of communication between
two people
as we have seen before I in this
scheme, we can simply observe
our suggestion is
trying to treat
this kind of interpersonal attunement
between two individuals
who are autistic and autistic,
for example, which might diverge
if left unnoticed by treating
not only the autistic individual,
but also the neurotypical individual,
and also trying
to take care of their interaction
with training
and between them
but in a way that of the end result,
we are left with a tune deaf
and not tuned to individuals.
So what we see
is that people can communicate smoothly
into the other
and the we don't care about identifying
ideal normal against the weeds.
Other
types and styles of
communication should conform
so in this work
concluding, taken together,
we have argued that social interaction
does indeed matter
across various contexts and
timescales.
And in fact we even consider the question
of social interaction
as a fundamental philosophical question.
And so argument
here is a genuinely existential one. Yes.
Without social interaction,
we cannot even exist as humans
thank you very much
for your kind of attention,
and I would like to thank
several people that have collaborated
with us across the last
five or six years in order for us
to accomplish
a vast amount of experiments
of about 400
people, and especially
my academic advisor, Leonard Zilber,
who assisted me
in the journey of the last six years.
Thank you very much.
I'll be happy now to receive any question
and to happily discuss
Excellent.
Maybe you can share your screen
and we can take it from there.
Well, thanks for this really amazing talk
that was truly something special
and we got a bunch of questions.
Maybe you can share
and then you'll return to regular mode.
Back to me.
You can share your screen in digits. Yes.
Yeah. Hmm.
So for everybody who's watching live,
we have a bunch of questions already,
and you can ask more,
and I'll just ask them just in the order
that they were presented.
So, Alex, a question.
What are the connections
or disconnections of the dialectical
perspectives that you brought up
and Monism or Markovic and Monism?
So can you please repeat this question?
Yeah.
How do we think about the similarities
and dissimilarities
of the dialectical perspectives
that you address and mark Jovian Monism.
Like, kind of remarkable
blanket everything Yes.
So I have recently
come across a couple of folks claiming
in Monism and I think from
your wisdom and colleagues and so on.
But fortunately, to be honest,
I haven't had the opportunity here
to go through these kind of accounts,
not to draw the similarities.
But I can tell you, for example,
our approach serves
a lot of commonalities.
For example, we spoke of multiple
states, for example, and colleagues
who have argued in favor
of a multi scale and nested
Markov blanket
process.
So our account serves commonalities
with these.
So it's kind of multi scale approaches.
How much of your research work
also goes through these kinds of
directions?
Perhaps one.
One difference might be that in our case,
we don't take the predictive active
inference account
strictly or theologically,
but we use it as a tool in order to model
and capture
specific parts of the process.
So we don't necessarily presuppose
and nested
a blanket scene in reality,
but we still view them
as a very useful way of interrogating
these kinds of processes formally.
Nice.
That really maps to the realism
instrumental ism
discussion
we've been having in these discussions.
So here's another question from Sasha.
She wrote, What activities
or mental states are amenable
to creating interpersonal attunement
for adults?
What kind of activities?
What kind of improvizational
or or synchronous or you're studying it
in a very specific case.
But as far as just our day to day life,
what kind of activities
do you think create that sort
of interpersonal two minute for adults?
OK. Yeah. So
as we saw in the presentation,
I give a simple
example of interpersonal humans
between a caregiver and a child
in order to stress
how this kind of interpersonal attunement
is crucial
and not just about our interpersonal
with humans.
But also about survival.
So we are we cannot escape.
I am actually interpersonal as human
because otherwise we don't exist
neither biologically
but not even as humans.
So what whatever we learn from language
and symbolic functions comes
from developmentally acquired knowledge.
And which has been, of course
being possible through
larger evolutionary schemes.
But after we gather this kind of
capacities,
I think actually another important point
is that
I feel that certain paradigms in the past
have been helpful
but also constitute certain
human functioning
as starting a taking for some process
minus a given start statically so,
and then try to interrogate how
these kinds of theories of mind process
play out in interactions.
So we see here
that if we take a more historical
developmental approach, we see that
of course one feedback to the other,
the individual level, to the collective,
what we see here, the primacy, you know,
we go to can we progress the collective.
So first we are
in tune with others
and then we build ourselves.
And in the adult life,
I believe social interaction itself
and the experience of the other
is what can allow us to assume
to others in different
in many different levels.
For example,
yes, as I said before, in isolated
places, the people do have the chance
to communicate with others.
Might, if one you want to use
a Bayesian terminology,
they might develop so six priors
in terms of their social expectations
but when they experience
other people from other places,
they're unable to
tune their beliefs into one.
Let's just freely speaking, for example,
in this case of so strictly formed
beliefs,
people might face
such a tremendous difficulty in updating
and like they need to use so much
analysis of their prior prior beliefs.
So they form the cross development,
which might even
escape
to other malicious strategies
in order to confirm their
the inner expectations to the outer
world, even by, for example, violence
or even killing, exterminating the other
because they cannot trust
up their minds
around the existence of other
and the manifestation of other types of
belief systems.
For example, you can see in the history,
for example, a lot of times when
people from different belief systems or
or even different
economic interests
close together,
and we see that many times, instead of
being able to adapt to each other,
people find them through each other.
So I think the key here is early AIDS
exposure to various forms
of life and to and beliefs.
So naturally, organically,
people can assume to each other.
I think as we saw, there are procedures
like language that might even be
maybe more liberal, but still a window
of this kind of for a human.
So I think we are more open
for tuning with others in the world
in an earlier age than later, but still
through experience
and both
through educating ourselves, for example,
but more crucially, such an approach
would even go further, suggesting
that individual training is not enough,
like even if we try to educate ourselves
and to
and realize that we have acquired biases
against other people,
this might not be enough
even to eliminate all implicit biases
and perhaps only in real practice
in the practice of real
time social interaction. This these
models, if you want them, can be rebuilt
Mm hmm.
Really important points.
Thanks for sharing that.
Another question
in the chat from Stephen is,
is there a hypothesis
that people on the autistic spectrum
exhibit different traits
due to perception and action dynamics
being different rather than, for example,
just the brain structures
limiting their generative model.
Please repeat the question.
I think so.
Yeah.
Is there a hypothesis that people
on the autism spectrum exhibit
different traits due to their perception
and action dynamics being different
rather than just their brain structures
being different?
Can you hear me?
Yes, sorry, but I'm sorry.
But I'm losing connection
at certain points. Hmm.
I can hear you. Perhaps.
Perhaps
my internet connection is not good.
How about just
if you could reload on your page.
And how can I fix it up?
Just hit the reload on your browser
on the window.
Nice.
You know?
Yep. Yep. Sound good?
Good.
OK, now I've seen you better and better.
Could you please repeat
the last question? Great.
Last question was, is there any
hypothesis that people on the autism
spectrum have different
traits due to their perception
and action dynamics being different
rather than just brain differences.
So if I understood correctly,
I disconnected my comment.
That's what I'm thinking.
Maybe I can hear a bit through the song
if I understand correctly.
Is that
whether acoustic people might differ
not only in terms of brain function,
but also
actual and perceptual space? Yes.
So yeah. Yeah. This exactly.
This exactly
what our hypothesis is putting upon.
It argues that people,
autistic people
and other so-called neurotypical people
might differ
across different levels of description
from brain function to
and so the way that they generate
expectations,
especially about the social world
and to the way
that they express this expectations,
especially about others
so grounded in individual accounts
of predictive
processing and active inference we are
you hear that
and in taking predictive
processing and active inference.
So two main pillars we see here
that when you conform to systems that
entertain completely different complaints
about different
styles of
generating and expressing
social expectations, and
this might create
images of human situation
where this style is
less spontaneous as we're currently
evolving and more and more divergent
situation.
So starting from simply taking
the precision of dating single brains
we can reach to through predictive
crossing, to generating
of social expectations about others
to and through active inference.
So the way we generate
or express or
express this expectation
through action for others,
and especially when we take into account
the other, also we see
how the similarity of the similarity
of these ways can contribute
and in different scenarios.
So for example,
borrowing the terminology
of dynamical system, for example,
one can see how this
how the how taking into how considering
these dyad, this one system
and how this system
can evolve
very differently when even when
a small mismatches up
is in the beginning of an interaction.
Banks and it just sort of
cracked me up because we're almost
replicating your experiment.
We're having a mediated
dialectic, a dialog
and then now you can see me,
but I can't see your face.
And yet there's even another level
of the affordance
with our friends and colleagues
who can ask us questions
and it's like everybody
has their own perspective.
Every question is coming
to the top of the mind for someone.
And then it's through that interaction
that we're who we are as individuals
and as a lab.
So just really cool to hear
how you brought complexity science
and all these different world
knowledge tradition together
to also address like very,
very prescient social issues.
So another question from the chat.
Yvonne asks
How can I be sure that someone else's
social beliefs are actually the
same as mine?
How can I believe?
How can
we how can I be sure that someone's
social beliefs are the same as mine?
OK. Yeah.
So for that,
I guess you can can never be sure
like this. Exactly.
The Bayesian framework also.
That's the beauty of something.
But we don't necessarily
dichotomized beliefs between for example,
sure are true, but we place
on our beliefs different levels of
different levels of confidence
or precision.
And like in a recent collaboration
with some colleagues,
as the legal case
before we examine
conceptually the problem of trust.
And there we argue, for example,
that trust in the personal trust
is is
is fundamental
in this kind of relationships.
So based on our belief of predictability
of the other
inconsistency and also that the other
would like to cheat as well.
So on a belief of billions
and also on shared values.
So we just accept that we have values
with some certain people
based on these three
points.
We argue that people should necessarily
and the thing trust
about others in social interactions
in order to make our
to make our
trust interaction functioning well.
We in fact argue with Christof more that
this is inescapable
practice in real life social interactions
because just because we are not able
to trust and monitor
every possible
incident around in our world.
So the next possibility
is just to get paranoid
and try to to control and monitor
the behavior of everybody
in order to have access to everybody's
beliefs and actions
but instead of
I think we as humans the trust,
which of course sometimes
we argue that's always crucial
like already from there gathering
from ancient societies,
like from Tomasello work,
we see how people based on trust
were able to handle more complex,
more complex
scenarios and provide for themselves
the means to survive
in ecological crisis.
And but we also argue that trust
also can go wrong at certain times.
And of course, in this in this case,
his betrayal of trust,
the whole them, the whole
the consequences can be dramatic
and both in individual and social level.
So these two, this work
where a little bit more is the first,
but also all probably true
in a lot of the cool.
Really nice point
about the trust in the sense making
you know, you're giving sentence
after sentence.
I just have to trust you.
It just and anything cognitively
that demands
more than just simply trusting you
is just not going to work.
So here's a question from Laura
in the chat.
Laura, writes, Thank you, Dr. Bolis.
I would like to know
if it would be necessary to standardize
the individuals from different cultures.
Conform, composing a dyad
to avoid distractors
when you evaluate the interaction.
So how do we think about culture
and the dyad?
How do we control or explore that?
Yes. So on hypothesis, I
would go beyond like
we used autism, I say paradigm example,
but go goes beyond that.
And how it could accommodate
any cultural or difference
or difference in beliefs
in a simple way.
Like I said, for example,
by the deploying dyad structure
where we have homogeneous structure
they have structure, for example,
people of the same
a cultural and people from the same
because who and mixed for example groups
and see how a different process play out
and then we can tease apart
a place
a certain extent which processes are
played out within specific countries
or with what process might emerge
out of just out of the communication
between cultures.
And then we can maybe see how
how the meeting of culture
can provide new possibilities.
For example,
in some countries just one aspect
in my mind, also
socioeconomic background, it's
also of huge importance.
So people are done differently
in cultural practices,
but they differ a lot
in their social economic background
and their intentions and motivations.
So some people
try to change certain
aspects of their social economic mix
because they are not satisfied.
And even in the level
that they cannot survive
as a group, other people try to preserve
and maintain certain
social, economic context, context.
So I think it's a very
a very diverse market.
And even in our case,
if we studied this the similarity
of these traits and consider
this oversimplification, we found some
interrelationship and friendship quality,
but still that's just one factor.
I think there are so many factors play
play out in interpersonal attunement,
which
is good
to try to isolate certain aspects.
But I think at the end of the day,
we should try to make a choice
to see the big picture in real life.
More.
It's almost like the ancients and their
different concepts of friendship,
different kinds of friendship,
or different words for friendship.
And so quality is going to be
a multidimensional attribute for student.
So Tadd asks the question
One thing that humans seem to excel
at is successfully interacting
with complete strangers.
People
we have not yet had time to attuned to.
How does your approach
explain or address this?
Yes. So as I said,
less interpersonal human
in the early development,
I think and attachment
theories are very important here.
So I think that
we are
embedded from day one to the social net
and social cultural net of our world.
And that's why we are able to communicate
with a complete stranger
because just simply
because we both are quite
common knowledge.
This can be language, for example.
So it's we can still communicate with
an animal, for example,
with our dog and
but less successfully usually
than with other humans.
But also we can see how dogs and humans
also came closer across evolution
and we are more apt
because we are in common ground here
and we are more able to communicate.
So imagine other types of animals
in more ways than one.
And usually we are more difficult
to communicate and make sense
of these animals.
But here again, trust
I think is very important.
So we grew up in
completely different places that same
completely different people.
But and we don't know how each other
grew up.
So but just by sharing common values and,
and common ground
and just by being able
to trust others,
this can make interaction functioning
like when,
for example, people of different cultures
invaded other places that they see
for the first time people
we saw atrocities, for example,
because people didn't trust
the people that they met
or they have, of course, other interests.
But we see that when we meet an unknown
person,
of course, both possibilities are open.
We can be kind and to functioning,
we can be also very vicious.
I mean, this is human species
across our history. Yep.
It's interesting
how you brought up the incentives
and the intentions almost separately
because there are situations
that could be win win,
but then the communication
or the narrative breaks down
and then there's atrocity
or there are cases when actually the game
theory is set up adversarial.
I remember also reminds me of
like our embodied
and cultured nature as humans
and what we share
even when we don't share language,
like when I've been traveling
and not spoken, the language
I'll see some street food
and it's like it's
you can communicate with your body
and with your actions that you think
it looks like great food
or that you want the food
and so it's like everyone tastes
the same taste molecules.
Maybe it's a preference culturally,
whether it's spicy or sweet, but then
that's still like a communication
and an interaction and an attunement
that is with money that one person
is not familiar with a language
and a context that's really nice.
I mean, basically.
I'll ask one more question
or is that cool?
Yes, yes.
Sure. OK, I have two more questions.
First one is where does active inference
come into play?
Or where do you see active inference
being able to sort of meet
this very large philosophical tradition
that you're bringing here?
You know, so
and as we
saw in the beginning of the presentation,
I, I see activity
present, predictive processing as
let's say
dialectical interplay of two strategies
has suggested from conversation
with other people before.
There's an interplay for making sense
of that and acting upon the world
in order for us to survive.
So I see active inference
as there is then
the active possibility we have
in order to maintain our living form. So
not just by conforming with environment,
but changing the environment.
And I found this very neat.
What I found when meeting this account is
that we can, with the same terminology,
we can account for both perceptual
learning
purposes and collective action.
So we see how our perception, learning
and action becomes just one more process.
That's
I see them as the electrical phenomena
and are as inseparable.
And what I try
when I start studying these processes,
some a nine years ago
in Zurich, this class and
this completely transformed
the way I see
even the world, say, myself,
but gradually start feeling
that just by focusing
on individual courses
or even more sort of inference
practices, crossing might
limit our scope of interpretation.
So these are exactly my peers
they have tried
to bring together different,
different philosophical
or scientific frameworks
to try to embed
this kind of account
in a more social, cultural,
real life context.
So in this in this effort, for example,
also of ecological
and active approaches
that I felt are instrumental also.
So, you know,
so I, I can,
I would like to see in the future
a fusion of philosophical approaches
that they see
the wholeness of the real life
phenomenon, such as dialectics with more
formal ways of interpreting data
such as active inference
and also more ecological
and active approach and complexity
approach dynamical system
in one in our study.
And to see, as I say, for example,
a 11 way I have seen these companies
that like simply perhaps
in one paper of ours, we suggested that
we not
bring together the Olympics
and then activism with active insurance.
We can still keep our emphasis
on social interactions
and the embeddedness or or of organisms
in the social work, but also
also using
powerful computational tools
to examine the individual brains
which are embedded in the system.
So I think an extension of this kind
of active inference accounts,
perhaps through one
such as Chris Matheson to Zamboni.
So what if they have proposed
to level metabolism
in approaches where
by deploying this they have they
so this is this kind of framework
for studying both learning and decision
making into levels.
And we have suggested
that we can re-appropriate
these kinds of models for studying
individual brains and collective action
in the same model.
And this to our suggestion is here,
but these two levels
might not even entertain
the same mechanisms
so in, in the brain,
we might have a certain way
of minimize prediction error
and keep a consistent form
in social interactions.
Between people might have different
mechanisms that might have been described
more efficiently with an activist,
for example, for dynamical systems.
But I think by bringing together
these tools and more complete
picture of both the sociological
processes and the actual mechanisms
of the biological level might
and how this feedback
to one
another might become more apparent.
So while, you know, I was going to ask
what the next research steps were,
that was quite an agenda.
I mean, it's really awesome.
Maybe just on a closing question, note,
what would you like to just close with
or where are we going to go from here?
What are your next research steps or what
are you excited to see the community
be looking into?
Yeah, I just mentioned
I would be very excited
to see this kind of a school of folks
coming more closely together.
I think more and more people are working
lately on this, bringing insights of
how more social interaction
all approaches and more
formal
brain approaches together,
and also of philosophy and practice.
I think it's very important here
is because you obviously do that
and like a fact, these
data are not never objective
facts
so as soon as we gather specific data
already we are in theory,
so only the way we deploy.
But I think philosophy is very important
here to
to form new experiments and new models,
not only for interpreting
data and also
this is from the research part,
but also the practice is very important.
So I would like
really these kind of approaches
to be used in practice in real life.
For example, in
psychiatry, it's one domain where we can
reexamine the more holistically certain
kind conditions,
for example, in the past,
which are more sociological,
more like social psychology examples.
Also the external factors and
impacts
of society and specific conditions
later, which have more cognitive model
where in biological genetic models
where we try to identify
redefine
psychiatric condition
based on the genetics or
cognitive abilities,
I would be very happy to see now
these two coming together
and one informs the other.
So a more evidence based
and holistic sociological approach
in in concrete concrete,
the applications of social policy
such as psychiatry, education,
and other societal
domains
wow. Very cool.
So thanks a lot for joining
this guest stream too.
It was really a great discussion
and really we're looking forward
to seeing what happens
with this line of research
and hopefully talking
to you and colleagues at future times.
So we'll certainly see you around.
Thank you very much.
For inviting and thank you very much
for your great initiative and providing
these seminars,
which are very illuminating so far.
Awesome.
Talk to you later
So bye.
Bye, bye!